de brousse et squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur fable natale free 10,3 il
est là malheureusement ces partis une
nouvelle partie basque à nouveau et on
va voir si on va être meilleure que dans
cette vidéo on va essayer de passer deux
nuits ok c'est notre objectif dans cette
vidéo c'est parti première nuit
ok le mec vient d'arrêter de parler il
n'y a pas de nouveauté [ __ ] je suis
carrément perdu premièrement la ya les
caméras et en fait bon on peut jouer un
titre
coup dur pour les attirer comme ceux-ci
ensuite on aussi maintenant les
ventilations voilà il ya des [ __ ] de
ventilation avec comme double clic
je crois que ça l'art est et on a un mot
de panneaux juste ici qui permet de
redémarrer le système audio donc le
bruit à l'amérique vélo les caméras ou
la ventilation autour bouter d'un coup
voilà ni plus ni moins du coup il ya
beaucoup plus de données que les eaux on
était déjà nos deux frenchies d'avant
s'il en est encore plus nul c'est
parfait ça fait autant plaisir à
j'aurais jamais dû faire ça [ __ ]
ah ben voilà pas sa première nuit voilà
la nuit tutoriel on l'appelle la nuit
des nuls allez deuxième nuit c'est quoi
ça qu'est-ce que je fais là je joue le
monstre qu'elle ait des liens là est
injuste autres un double le nounours
mais pour quoi faire au l'homme est
homme et sa part en steak à mort face à
lui je vais révoquer follow me et par à
droite quoi r je peux pas y aller aux
mondiaux il ya un truc qui a tué le truc
qui me tue moi chaque famille est à peu
près 10 en or et un nouveau mot ce que
média puis sort ne me faites pas la
blague aa et ont aidé et il va nous
expliquer le monsieur téléphone oui
alors quand ils achètent erreur ou je
redémarre la ventilation c'est ça ok
d'accord dont des fois y'a un truc qui
bug il faut que je redémarre et je peux
pas quitter le panneau pour dr d'abord
je les vois pas en plus ces [ __ ] de
mont soleil a même plus d'histoires de
batterie on peut même plus fermer les
portes
c'est la mère de famille n'a je vous dis
c'est la merde regardez les arènes à
fermer ici bordel et à droite non plus
s'il est bien il vient on meurt au jaune
est bien passé là devant vous jure
qu'aider à semur là ils regardent les
dessins mais de l'autre côté des
allumeurs jeunes importe quoi vous
attire loin les deux heures du match
audience très sûr pour avoir fait 28
dans cet endroit diabolique ventilation
erreurs mais qui a installé cette
ventilation quoi on lance pas la leur
star et on ferme le panneau ah parce que
comme ça qu'on le retire on a le stress
en mairie est là et du coup mal à tirer
la ola là je cache pas sa tête avec le
panneau biatch ok c'est pas marché
oh [ __ ] mais comment je fais partie
comment je la fais partir c'est reparti
pour la nuit de en fait il ya ce putin
d'année matronic qui va nous dire coucou
il nous défoncer mais on n'aime pas trop
juste que je comprenne comment le faire
fuir mais je pense que c'est avec le
bruit en fait faut juste faire un bruit
qui l'attirent ailleurs et le trouver
j'ai vu aucun mec depuis le début dans
ces foutus caméra tu as real ya les
têtes des anciens qui émettent de la
lumière mais les enseignes sont plus là
en fait bien plus qu'un animatroniques
est là et qui veut nous nous défoncer la
tuer les anciens ont entamé l'ascension
où il a fait tellement de frayeur
tellement de câlins ça c'est très malin
parce qu'on croit toujours qui est un
mec du coup qu'elle a alors que pas du
tout bravo développeur a en fait
l'animatronique y passent par les
ventilations à hénon peuvent fermer la
ventilation et du couffo que je trouve
où il est que je ferme la ventilation en
question certains c'est chaud il est 4
heures du matin on est toujours en vie
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe monsieur
owens regardez là dedans mais juste
investissez dans des caméras à la fin
avant vous avez une batterie de merde
maintenant c'est les caméras qui sont
pourris pas il est dans les [ __ ] de
conduits et pourquoi pas des caméras
dans les conduits on va arrêter de se
poser les questions à la fin les choses
sont comme elles sont nous devons faire
face à ses difficultés c'est de faire
une morale pour faire mieux passer la
frayeur qui nous attend finalement
aubry je suis seul dans ma chambre et
j'ai pas de comptage et pas chez doit
donc en fait là qu'en juin des anciens
je pense qu'en fait c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec l'ennemi tronic donc on voit
là une main truc nous défoncer voilà
c'est l'heure de la 3ème nuit
il ya des caméras dans les conduits jeu
complètement con mais je vois jamais le
mic est dedans bizarrement du coup en
fait il ya deux fois plus de caméras à
gérer il est toujours mes nuits
je m'attendais à ce qu'il soit 3h merde
on a ville et là on va fermer ce conduit
la revoilà parce qu'on n'a pas de
courage monsieur ho [ __ ] vidéo erreur
parfait c'est tout ce qu'on voulait
aller redémarre il est là c'était un jeu
partout et dont je pars touché au bas
dit il ya un près de ventilation
j'arrive plus à respirer ventilation
redémarre oui c'est mon cas aussi il un
problème de ventilation faut le ventiler
qu'on n'est pas mort mais comment ça se
fait qu'on n'est pas mort je préférais
crever bordel isère et niveau des rondes
rire il est là il est là regardez le
ferment ce conduit c'est bon c'est fermé
alors tu passes par au fdp se taquine
mais été bloqué les stats aikin audio et
or c'est pas grave on redémarre
c'est comme un pc il faut le redémarrer
comme ça marche plus a fabriqué un cheat
un cheat un programme que tu télécharges
et ça accélère le temps qui passe
d'entrée 10 on aura passé trois drops
matin c'est plus que dans les deux
autres vidéos qu'on a fait sur free
viserait une idée moi je tout ému par
mes émotions discrètement je pense t on
peut pas le voir un petit resserrage de
doigts comme ça ni vu ni connu ces
communes plus électrique le téton 1 chez
un homme c'est la fin cela
il n'y a que dans x nasa free discuter
contente d'entendre histoire de réveil
dans toute situation tu n'es plus du
tout contente envie tout péter au du
coup on joue le deuxième
le premier s'est fait défoncer la gueule
et de deux morts deux trois hommes nus
je comprends rien à ce qui se trouve des
choses hyper intéressante il nous dit le
pourquoi du comment je ne comprends rien
à ce que tu dis parce que je suis
terrifiée déjà qu'en temps normal si vtf
je ne suis pas mort donc c'est plutôt
heureux malheureusement ils prennent en
compte il assure actuellement ça mais
l'aventuré seul fait que brouiller quoi
ça suffit bordel je suis quand même pas
lui qui la contrôle c'est mon patron il
pas content de moi allez on se
débarrasse de cette employée au alors qu
il était là où l'herbe ou un truc c'est
que ces objets de l'atv lointain je vais
je veux attirer vers la vers la mer là
et là ô ô va chier à température
cette équipe d'autodéfense que ma prime
roussely hockey olala c'est là que ça
devient record 1 à la ils font pas
semblant on passera cette troisième lui
vous m'entendez c'est peut-être pour ça
que je vois jamais il fait complètement
oublier les caméras je sais pas bas sur
cette [ __ ] de caméras j'ai fait un max
de bruit n'est pas là quand même non pas
encore ça fait que tard des jackson five
et l'art vidéo erreurs mais vas-y mais
c'est microsoft qui est déjà ce système
de surveillance moi je vous le dire pour
que ton de bug ça va nickel audio error
ventilation erreurs et bottom aller le
décès [ __ ] les mecs mais par toi non
elle a bougé il a bougé la bouche on
sait qu'il est à gauche en train
d'observer juste là non c'est bon on est
partis parti il est là ouais je suis pas
mort mais la motivation est cassé
d'accord mais laisse moi un peu de répit
à la fois sa semaine une station de
sarkozystes qui joua femme nathalie 10
il est beaucoup trop rapides beaucoup
trop fluide audio error au nom non plus
d'heures aux boucles audio je peux pas
d'attirer alors j'ai l'impression de
voir un mec qui faisait un spectacle de
maracas devant moi il est une heure du
matin peut pas mourir ordinateur et toi
aussi dans la foulée à bas on commence à
être habitué à voir ses petits game over
1 ou lourds tentent j'y arriverai un
jour j'arriverai il fait du bruit et
goûter voilà on sait repérer à cause de
quoi
à cause de lui ohlala bhutto l'aller nos
missiles sa cache tout cette
animatroniques ils bouffent les caps et
comme un lapin finalement mais peut-être
survie des croquettes comme un lapin il
va être docile
on ne sait pas toujours ceux conduits là
qu'est fermé logiquement je la tire un
endroit plutôt stratégique dans la dans
la stratégique faire j'aime ce qu'un
tramway qui passe ça me fait penser à un
tramway chez moi pourquoi donc est ce
que cette animatrice ne veut pas
gentiment monter dans ce tramway est
allé profondément se faire [ __ ] un
truc à beugin audio device c'est
important c'est pour la tirade est en
droit de a b c comme en mathématiques
comme moi tiens à dire la chronique d'un
point a à un point b sur une comparé à l
on est chaud là on est chez moi je vous
le dis il vient au lieu dit c'est pas
j'ai fait un stage elle bruce lee lille
c'est pas fameux stage de troisième dont
vous êtes en parler mais dit le dire à
personne mais je vous le dis il est
juste en face dans le voit quand je
regarde sa branche bien tout petit peu
fait
oui au tce violente on a pu remarquer ce
sont en tout cas si je passais cette
troisième nuit dans trois années on va
la tirer
ici on va couper ce conduit ensuite
faire un truc bien stratégiques par
exemple se gratter la narine voyez on a
bien fait de la tyrie puisque le conduit
est bloqué en dessous il a disparu
aïe aïe tramway les dents mais m j'ai
enchaîné 3 0 mais par seconde quoi ça
voulait rien dire et j'en ai absolument
à neuf et malmedy mon cerveau wild card
pour ces remous le truc et balla balla
balla balla passe par la passe par le
conduit tout droit à tout droit je veux
pas je m'en foutais maracas tu l'as
compris à la fin voilà je m'en fous
attention à ce qui se passe de ce côté
là voilà c'est comme quand on fait un
malaise on lève les jambes mais moi je
lève les bras donc en fait je lève les
bras pour faire un malaise du coup oh
[ __ ] là quand ça commence à transpirer
sais c'est que c'est très très pas bien
et quand ça commence à mal par les c'est
que c'est encore moins bien aller passe
à 4 heures du matin saloperie
d'informatique
allez allez notre cv va encore elle est
juste là et on a bien fait at il pas ce
qu'on va faire mais qu'on dit peut pas
dire beaucoup
il peut être vous savez très bien les
hommes suit ça veut dire qu'on fait ça
en était c'est pas l'été je m'en bats
les steaks tétouan chagas tout le monde
fait un peu pitié dans cette vidéo elle
est passée à 5 heures mec passenans à 6
heures en plus et il est là où je suis
pas bon je suis pas dans le bas valais
c'est jean-michel pachuca départ et la
ventilation jamais ça bien de passer à 5
heures du matin je dois tenir une heure
supplémentaire à savoir je sais pas
combien de temps ça fait jamais ce que
ça fait une vraie or attirons le la
veyron yeux et oreilles bien il vient y
vient et bien j'ai vu je les ai vus j'ai
vu j'ai vu c'est la fin on va là tiré la
balle à ben arfa là bas il ya un
problème d'audience je suis mort c'est
simple tu m'en aille à coadout ou audio
vidéo je ne dis pas que non non pitié
pitié
j'vais piano sur mon front ça marche
vraiment regarder
le problème vous êtes jaloux je sais
c'est ça doit acter sa désavantage c'est
incroyable ce qui vient de se passer
bordel regarder on joue le le petit
dernier comme ça je fais soufflerait et
va te faire tuer tu vas décédé juste à
côté du bleu juste la voilà et ensuite
c'est la quatrième nuit
eh bien non et bien avant ses offres web
à l'agencé tap que cette fois la vidéo
sur problèmes d'alcool et 10,3 n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo elle me dit encore
dire si vous voulez pour finir le jeu
même si je doute que nos capacités au
niveau des aisselles se produira pas
assez transpiration qu'on puisse finir
il importe quoi mais je suis tout ému
[ __ ] je suis tellement content c'est
incroyable bah on regardait sans doute
vu dans une nouvelle vidéo tient tout le
monde quand et vous bien ça oui monsieur
c'est pourquoi là on part sur un panneau
solaire qui va alimenter les mêmes le
véhicule
c'est totalement faux mais j'aime bien
faire ce métier que j'aime beaucoup
c'est pas cool